guys don't like what implants implants
who like just random dudes oh so they
just made a blanket statement yeah all
guys don't like fake yeah that's funny
because why is it a thing yes really why
is it a thing wait wait so that that
comment kind of feeds into in my my
opinion it kind of feeds into the whole
thing about well then women are doing it
for men some old people deserve to be
abandoned in retirement homes 100 shout
out to my grandpa hope he's [ __ ]
burning hell and die in there oh Jesus
oh yeah I would [ __ ] Chuck them in
there so why would we feel bad for bad
people when they become fragile like I
think about this all the time too like
we see these fragile little old wrinkly
things they're so cute and small and
helpless whatever we want to protect
them but also at the same time like
whenever I see that I was like oh he's
so cute and then in the back of my
head's like he was what if he was a
rapist if we can end the suffering of
animals with euthanasia then we should
totally be able to make that choice
ourselves when we're at our point where
we can't do anything there was this
concept that uh someone designed like a
roller coaster oh yeah it's like an
index roller coaster yeah like it kills
you absolutely not there's like nine
nine that's like Circle yeah no I think
they were pretty cool for you because
you're watching my face that's an
unpopular opinion right there there's a
picture
everyone uh the screen 12. she's alive
and then she's gone oh you get it like a
photo at the end
I read recently that they're working on
uh suicide boots too boots
[Music]
but
tons
hello everyone welcome back to the
podcast
my name is Jessica I will be your host
today
who do we have here hi it's Gina how
long has it been since we had just
hosting I know I don't know yeah she's
forever ago anyway I'm Tiff thanks for
being here ladies thanks for coming over
to my house everyone I like suddenly
lost all the ability to speak it's the
first episode of the day yeah so we just
gotta we're a little bit tired
we all had coffee I put a little meth in
their coffee so it should kick in soon
yeah I don't think I had enough coffee
maybe we should get two is nothing upper
or a downer meth is an upper what do you
mean is it I don't know about that like
I know about meth
I'm surprised you don't right I feel
like that's common knowledge
like she's over compensating like wait
is the sky blue no it's like everyone
like the way I look and the work that I
used to do like Go-Go dancing everyone
thought like oh she must know a lot
about it but one time I was Go-Go
dancing and I went upstairs and they
were filling up balloons and my I wasn't
my girlfriend I was like oh balloons and
she goes oh my god did you no no no yeah
yeah
today I wanted to talk about some
unpopular opinions I feel like we
haven't done an episode on that in a
while yeah yeah
um and since I've let you all know that
one of my favorite websites now is
Reddit yeah I feel like uh let's just go
and use Reddit for some content I'm
gonna throw mine out
and you guys know this too Bohemian
Rhapsody is a stupid [ __ ] you know what
garbage garbage song all right just [ __ ]
off I'll fight with anyone no class
no no music so taste and no class my
reason being all right it's like 16
songs put into one picture
the main thing is it's a selfish song
When You Go Karaoke because it's like is
that the only reason you hate it
yes but the actual song itself still
annoying though it's a little bit too
much of everything I like it it takes
you through a journey the song is three
hours long we paid an hour like we paid
like per hour at the [ __ ] karaoke
place Kitty and somebody wants to choose
the same damn song I want your cat to
say something into the mic right I
really wish you feel about it speak on
command
now you're quiet you're freaking
interrupting our show all day long with
your meows and then we get we give you
the mic and you don't want to say [ __ ]
be shy unpopular opinion Gina's cat is
an [ __ ] that's probably a popular
opinion my mic keeps falling let's see
here okay your mic is fighting you and
you're like it's gonna fall over and
just like hit me in the face if you're
on YouTube you might enjoy that
um okay so I'm just gonna kind of scroll
through here see if you have any
reaction to any of these okay if you
don't passionately if you don't we can
move on but if you do let me know how
you feel let me find a good first one
here police should be tested for drugs
regularly yes oh yeah that's an
unpopular opinion I agree I feel like
any important role of authority should
be tested not only that and
psychologically just I like I don't know
what the standards are for police people
at all like I don't follow anything but
I do know that they don't get physically
tested regularly is just once they get
out of their the academy they get the
test the physical test oh that's why we
see kind of a lot of un yeah out of
shape yeah they should be having that
physical test regularly
yeah or not I could use some hoops so
slow as well yeah you know sometimes we
eat those when we're committing crimes
yeah it's funny too because I think like
they do get tested for steroids right
but then it's almost like I'd rather
them be on steroids well maybe not
because there's no outrage yeah but like
that seems to be more in the direction
that I would want them to go right to be
like working out yeah maybe a small
amount of steroids like to because they
get old men lose testosterone and stuff
like that that seems maybe it's more
fine they can't take it at all yeah yeah
that's weird that weird I don't know why
is that the priority here yeah I don't
know there's other jobs like a computer
desk job that gets drug tested yeah well
why is our law enforcement not getting
drug tested yeah especially when there's
a lot of uh criminal activity that they
could engage in yeah yeah exactly
they're literally in contact with drugs
yeah weird that's crazy well let's get
on something maybe a little less
difficult I can't yeah I don't know
anyone like
not agreeing with that that's weird yeah
it was on here weird to me
all right let's get to it's a little
more funny this one says no one actually
hates mayonnaise oh my god do you think
that's do people actually hate
mayonnaise or is this just like a trend
and it's dumb I've posted on Twitter
last week like what's your hot take when
it comes to food and so many people said
I don't like mayonnaise I'm like oh okay
so what's it like to be a [ __ ] racist
wait these people
what that's mayonnaise I don't know how
it's racist but I'll figure it out look
there's this white guy that responded
saying mayonnaise is disgusting and I
said
a white man hating mayonnaise and an
Asian woman defending it I never thought
this day would come yeah but how dare
you do you actually like mayonnaise or
do you like the Japanese mayonnaise no I
love Manny's periods okay so just the
feeling only one Manny's like you can
eat it with nothing I was such a
disgusting kid with like I remember
going to visit my siblings because we
lived separately and they're like tried
us out we were like six years old we
used to eat tortilla chips dipped in
mayonnaise oh God now that I think about
it gross so back then it was the [ __ ]
I mean with some flavoring like that's
why I guess aioli is a thing right like
because you add some flavor okay that's
why I don't like it I get that some of
them are not good so I really don't like
it I'm actually uh extremely white trash
so I prefer Miracle Whip over mayonnaise
I've never tried Miracle wood it's just
sugar inside of mayonnaise it's kind of
like the Japanese one what is it QP man
or whatever yeah
I guess you have for sure you have okay
not not knowingly yeah
um no I like mayonnaise only when it's
like with things I've never like I would
not eat mayonnaise on its own no one
does well it's oil like you're not gonna
just sit there and eat peanut oil
there's people who just like butter on a
stick I've I've read okay that's crazy
but I mean you eat butter on toast right
yeah just basically eating oil on bread
yeah and it tastes pretty good it does
salted butter is pretty legit yeah
especially to finish off a steak with
some salted butter delicious I've never
had Miracle Whip and mayonnaise decide
to compare so I can't tell the
difference just well so I have to I
think you have an activity I always
thought Miracle Whip was like whipped
cream no like for desserts it's a Fluff
what was that wait is it am I saying the
wrong thing
oh my god Jess is wrong no fluffered
letters or whatever is the fluffy what
the [ __ ] is the Mayo that's it yeah
no you just [ __ ] up my head no Miracle
Whip is the sweet man yeah okay oh my
God just down
I just had a brain fart because I
pictured whipped cream and I was like
have I been saying the wrong thing the
whole time wait what the [ __ ] is
whatever happens I'm savoring everything
um
hold on we're going down this [ __ ]
path right now this is ready for Cool
Whip is the [ __ ] okay so there's a
Miracle Whip Miracle Whip is mayonnaise
okay so it is why is it called the whip
because it's whipped with sugar oh
probably I don't [ __ ] know fluff or
not there's a sandwich made with peanut
butter and marshmallow cream you've
never heard of that white bread ooh that
sounds good that sounds very white trash
I've never heard of that word yeah I've
never heard fluffernutter oh never heard
of that in my life heard of it on TV I
think but it sounds
I would try it yeah peanut butter with
marshmallow I would try it on scent
white sandwich but I am a marshmallow
fan oh I don't like marshmallows I can
do mushrooms at Springtime give me all
the peeps delicious don't give a [ __ ]
what you think you know what also like
candy corn and the candy girl
with the only peeps lost me on the Candy
Corn so you're that one person that's
been keeping peeps in business yes and
candy corn Yes actually there's a lot of
people like me that's why we get the
whole front of the grocery store during
Springtime I think it's a lot licorice
disgusting oh
yeah black is disgusting it's like the
weirdest flavor ever yeah it's like
medicine yeah it tastes like medicine
even Red Vines I don't like I love red I
love Twizzlers I hate Twizzlers okay
Twizzlers or the regular Twizzlers okay
they give me a headache every time I
feel like I always eat too many and then
I get sick
just the smell gives me it like makes me
want to think it's like I don't know
plastic yeah like most of our food is
disgusting like fruit loops and all the
stuff that we grew up on is actually
pretty I like how people like talk [ __ ]
about how Asian people eat crazy things
when you guys are eating
spray can
the [ __ ] listen don't break my reality
okay
I was telling them the other day I was
like I came to Los Angeles with a small
mind yeah small food palette you guys
broke me we had to teach her so many
things yeah
she was like she was like the one that
goes to the steakhouse and orders like
chicken fingers I would order a steak at
a steakhouse okay but like comfortably
to like no she was she was the one
ordering chicken teriyaki at the sushi
spot yeah
eating raw fish who the [ __ ] are you
like no thank you we eat our fish cooked
and then ask it when she flew in yeah
immediately yeah I was like I need some
[ __ ] Korean food or something some
[ __ ] something in nature
all right yeah so here's another one
this one's kind of funny she's a it's a
as a girl who doesn't drink a lot but
gets bought drinks for men when I go out
I wish it was actually acceptable to
send me a plate of chicken wings instead
yeah that was an unpopular opinion well
number one it probably costs a lot more
true no wait does it yeah I feel like a
plate of chicken wings well actually if
you're at like a a bar could be like 14
for a nice cocktail yeah and then a
plate of chicken wings might be like 14
or 18 right
but it's kind of weird that's so funny
mom here's a plate of chicken wings from
the guy down there
it has cheers
also you don't know but like I only like
the flappers so if I get a bunch of
these nasty shitty little drumsticks I'm
gonna be so annoyed you're you're a flat
person Flats only I like drums so
complicated spots are amazing they taste
way better really they don't have all
those they don't have all the nasty
[ __ ] ligaments and [ __ ] I love that
part I don't know about the different
and difference in flavor but for sure
like the bones are more difficult if
it's cooked right all you gotta do is go
no yeah
and then you just take the two bones out
I learned that but the drums like I
really don't like tendon and drums
obviously yeah exactly it's so flat all
the way
we call them Flappers at Hooters but
when I when I worked there well you said
I only deal with Flappers I'm like is
that a type of drink or like where's she
going with this the flats the just the
flat chicken yeah I mean if they're
cooked like in a like a wet sauce and
soft you can just Bob then like I like
mine dry rub no the dry ones the ones in
[ __ ] Japan
style chicken wings like if they're
cooked properly you could do the same
thing
um
I like to eat my wings with one hand
no bone in the middle that I can stick
my tongue in and pull the meat out you
know the the bone in the middle
you're getting that's two hands you're
getting chicken wings that are like
poorly cooked basically is the problem
so bad I love when you stop yeah
Wingstop is kind of disgusting unpopular
opinion they're really dry really dry
they're just hit or miss
every single location is like it really
is it really depends on who's back there
you know truly but their fries are
pretty good
someone said
um milkshakes are better than ice cream
I don't like sweets I can't weigh in on
this okay what do you think ice cream
milkshakes are better than ice cream no
I don't agree I don't agree there I
don't but you know when I was a little
kid I would one of my favorite things to
do is to get just vanilla plain vanilla
ice cream like put it in a bowl and then
just like stir the [ __ ] out of it to
kind of like make it into a milkshake in
my bowl and then eat it like that yeah
Casey likes but I don't mix it with
music like
yeah I the part that the reason why I
decided to know is because when I have a
bowl of ice cream and there's just all
that melted ice cream at the bottom
that's a waste of ice cream for me
because I don't like that it's liquidy
yeah I want it solid I like it when it's
like just Across the Threshold from
being like a hard a harder thing that
you have to kind of scoop to like in the
middle of that soft serving so it's kind
of like soft Serbia so I like make my
own Soft Serve by like stirring the [ __ ]
out of it okay here's the reason why I
don't even like sweets but I'll choose
one over the other and it's for like a
really dumb reason ice cream I think I'd
rather choose ice cream and not
smoothies
because milkshakes are so [ __ ] thick
right you have to suck it with a straw
yeah and years ago I learned to try not
to drink or eat much wood straw or smoke
cigarettes because you get wrinkles
around your lips because you're going
the whole time and like when you're
drinking a [ __ ] milkshake it just
it sucks so hard and now I'm gonna get
wrinkles around my lips so this is all
for vain reasons
you could also eat a milkshake with a
spoon that's true but then like that's
not the
ice cream
your face
I only saw your face hers was like so
disgusting that you would bother eating
ice cream like in a less hard manner
the texture is different texture changes
food I don't like super cold foods
that's why I don't you're so weird I
know okay there's this girl at my work
who doesn't like cold food at all so she
has to like everything has to be hot and
microwaved extra and like super hot all
the time so I don't like super hot
either yeah okay yeah because then it's
like I have to wait for my food or burn
myself you know like if you notice
yesterday I made a cup of tea for you I
put mostly hot water in really cold
water so it's like ready to drink yeah I
noticed that I can't stand that [ __ ] I
don't like I always burn my tongue yeah
it's the waiting is but also part of the
waiting is like the tea is steeping so
like I feel like my tea is probably not
as strong because it didn't get to steep
in boiling water oh so you kind of
[ __ ] me on that no I'm that dumb [ __ ]
where like if it's something really hot
I set it down to cool yeah
another one and then I forget I've done
that before like at home because I drink
tea a lot at home and I'm like oh it's
been an hour yeah I forgot the t's been
sitting there because I just get like
lost I'm so strong yeah yo let me talk
about something I'm actually obsessed
with in love with can't get enough of
and that is Bay's luggage oh have you
tried it I am constantly amazed at Bays
wow we rhymed babes was created by
actress Shea Mitchell to make sleek and
affordable bags luggage and accessories
designed to help you travel effortlessly
while still looking fashionable and boy
did she deliver okay so I have the
carry-on hard shell luggage and a
matching like Weekender bag not only
does it hold my laptop it has like a I
have a 15 inch laptop and it has a
laptop cover protection fits everything
my makeup uh my books my journal all my
annoying things that I need like my
whole life on the plane with me to be
honest and then the bottom unzips and I
like to put shoes in there I can fit
three pairs of shoes in there and then I
don't have to waste room inside my
actual carry-on luggage girl I can pack
for over a week over a week with these
luggage items and what I love most about
it is that uh well those things the bag
rolls really smoothly and then the
Weekender bag has a trolley that you can
put on the handle of the Rolling bag
okay you have a visual in your head
because it is more effortless than my
description but anyway whether you're
packing for a quick trip or looking to
Breeze through a security line these has
your personal items covered and right
now base is offering our listeners 15
off your first purchase by visiting
phasetravel.com big mood go to
baystravel.com big mood for 15 off your
first purchase that's
b-e-i-s
travel.com slash big mood you're gonna
wanna go now okay here's another one
just because a movie has a message or a
deep meaning doesn't mean it's actually
a good movie True yeah why do we feel
like if something serious we have to
treat what makes it a good movie then I
think that's subjective
I like really cool plot twists that I
don't see coming like in Squid games
um I like lots of emotional
like I was just talking earlier
um how at the end of season one of Game
of Thrones I'm like oh they're not gonna
kill any music the main character and
then they killed our boy nutty Stark and
then I had to go and just pause and walk
out of the room yeah you know yeah like
that unexpected yeah yeah it's high
emotions I think they're saying kind of
like it also creates a scapegoat for the
movie like if it's bad and the directors
kind of know people will be like yeah
you just didn't get it like there's a
message to this like it kind of like
puts in like tenant I didn't actually
watch tenant I tried to start it and I
couldn't get through it so I liked tenet
but I was very angry watching it because
it was so loud and I couldn't [ __ ]
hear anything loud because we watched it
in the theater and I need subtitles
there were no yes you know what I've
always been against you on that but then
I started watching the The Game of
Thrones prequel the other day and I was
like thank you I'm just gonna put the
subtitles on because these [ __ ]
accents are crazy accents people Mumble
yeah the sound design is not good yes
who edited this yeah yeah and then
Christian Noel is like or Nolan he's
like yeah I did that on purpose because
it's not about the dialogue it's about
whatever where I'm like what the [ __ ]
I feel like I was totally against you
and then there was another one have you
seen have you started on Netflix and the
Sandman so that's another one where I
was like I [ __ ] need subtitles
because I can't or also it's like when
the the dialogue is very thick like
they're like it's real heavy be words
like a lot of old-timey words and stuff
like that like I just start to my brain
I'm just like yeah what the [ __ ] are
y'all talking about so if I can read it
then I'll like actually pay attention
when eating something really crunchy in
your mouth and you can't hear that well
you know it's either chips or the
episode yeah
um
or like you have to be quiet because a
baby's sleeping yeah you have to have it
on so you know what the hell's going on
I love stuff I've never done titles I've
always thought it was annoying but I
used to think that when I was a lot
younger and maybe we had better years
yeah and they learned how to read
no I used to hate it because I did I
used to think it distracted me from the
movie yeah cause I'm like I'm trying
like I can't watch the movie if I'm
reading the thing but then now I'm like
I literally don't know what's happening
if I'm not reading the thing you think
what the [ __ ] is happening that's so
true yeah I think once I once I I think
because I was at your house and we had
to watch the [ __ ] Selena thing with
the subtitles on and I was like God
these [ __ ] subtitles and then I just
got so used to reading it but then I do
notice it is extra work to like yeah to
read and then make sure you also see
what happens yeah because you see some
of it like peripherally but not yeah but
then like I I'm so used to reading
subtitles while I'm watching something
that I don't even notice that I'm doing
it like it's like it's all one for me I
can't do that like on YouTube though
like if I'm watching a YouTube video
like no subtitles they can't I can't
deal with that I always need it I feel
like I can't hear without the subtitles
it's weird
okay here's another one that's probably
going to piss me off it's literally fine
to take your boyfriend's opinion into
account and then so they give some more
context here says every time I see a
girl say my boyfriend likes this so I
did it or some variation in comes a
bunch of girls saying the same damn
thing it's not his body he gets no say
and while it's true it's not his body
it's perfectly fine for a woman to want
to be sexually attractive to her
boyfriend and change something that
suits his preference more why do we get
mad at that yeah wait I'm okay with that
or like then her own it's fine to take
your boyfriend's opinion into account
when I guess when it comes to things
with your body or your choices or
whatever like little things like I'll
ask my boyfriend like what color do you
like me in mostly do you like me in red
yeah he's like yeah I do I'm like okay
or like he's like my favorite color on
you as red I'm like okay then I make it
a point to wear more red because it's
little inconsequential things to show
that I care about your opinion I mean
because I have an opinion on like I'm
like don't [ __ ] wear the
if he's saying things like no you have
to go get your boobs on because your
tits are too small oh God that's [ __ ]
dumb
[ __ ] you know but if it's small into
console what about the opposite because
that's what Casey was telling me when I
wanted to get my boobs done he's like no
I like your boobs how they are like you
know but then they can use them anyways
but it could also be like his like
reverse your apology yeah
he's like you're not gonna catch me
saying you need to I know exactly he's
playing it smart yeah no but I honestly
truly did not even like
for yourself just because of the whole
mommy situation that kind of
breastfeeding I just didn't feel like I
was in my own body anymore yeah
for big decisions like that you choose
your own thing but just small things
yeah it's fine whatever I remember
before I got mine done and I was saying
that I was going to get it done a bunch
of people like a bunch of guys like no
guys don't like that so guys don't like
wood implants implants who like just
random dudes oh so they just made a
blanket statement yeah all guys don't
like fake yeah that's funny because why
is it a thing yes really why is it a
thing wait wait so that that comment
kind of feeds into in my my opinion it
kind of feeds into the whole thing about
well then women are doing it for men
when I got my boobs done
or like when I decided to get done and
then guys were like oh guys I don't like
that I swear to Jesus Christ there was
never a point where I thought to myself
the reason why I'm getting this done is
also because I want guys to like me more
never
possibly subconscious no because I my
main thing was
I just want to fit my clothes better and
I was a go-go dancer yeah you know and I
just like I want to fit my clothes
better and look cuter and that I feel
that too because like I haven't even
been with a man I haven't even touched a
man in a long time sometimes I'm like I
wish my boobs could actually like fill
this out or because I have such broad
shoulders and a flat chest but then like
wide hips and like I feel unbalanced
when I look at myself sometimes so I'm
like I feel like that would just make me
look more feminine or whatever like I'm
not gonna do it because a I feel like
the boobs themselves I've gotten so used
to being flat chested I feel like now I
have to deal with a whole new appendage
in a way and I was like now I have an
extra arm whatever the [ __ ] do I do with
this extra arm but like I get that but
I'm also I'm like is there even like a
tiny percent of me that even thinks
that's a thing just because that's the
model body that men also like and so
I've soaked a little bit of that in yeah
like I just didn't that they like this
shape or that this shape is the good
shape yeah that's why when you just
commented like well if guys didn't like
it then it wouldn't be a thing yeah like
that is kind of interesting well that's
like a that's like a side effect too
right right it's like if they if they
were literally vomiting in the streets
because women had fake titties I feel
like it would be less of a thing but not
that every single person who gets them
is just getting them for men yeah it's
not like Primal things side effects like
actual like boobs it Taps into like the
Primal uh thing for looking at a partner
right because you big boobs mean like
there's a lot of milk for your Offspring
yeah same with like you have like why
you have the proper burning hip hormones
yeah for a baby right like maybe I don't
have the proper balance of hormones for
a baby so that's why I look more manly
or something you know what I mean like
maybe in your in your lizard brain you
know I guess that's the same thing with
women like they want like strong
masculine men so they can right protect
her and that's why height is a thing
with women yeah but not all I mean
obviously there's huge grayers but yeah
I don't know
that's crazy it's like I ever said that
to me I would be like bye
I don't like that well
yeah I think it's like I don't know I
the internet is definitely quick to and
I am also definitely quick to be like
don't [ __ ] care so much about what
guys think or whatever but also it's
okay I do also have expectations on
other people or like I would have an
opinion on what he's wearing or what
he's doing with his hair or whatever so
that type of [ __ ] is perfectly in my
opinion perfectly fine yeah you don't
necessarily have to do it if he's like
oh you've been blonde your whole life
but now I would like you to be a
brunette I'm like you know how much this
[ __ ] cost me over the years yeah now
you want me to be brunette like [ __ ] you
yeah sorry no but you know it's too okay
here's another one
some old people deserve to be abandoned
in retirement homes 100 shout out to my
grandpa hope he's [ __ ] burning hell
and die in there Jesus oh yeah I would
[ __ ] Chuck him in there so why would
we feel bad for bad people when they
become fragile and feel like none of
them why do you think in general I think
they all of a sudden become innocent I
think human nature itself it's because
like when we see little old like I think
about this all the time too like we see
these fragile little old wrinkly things
they're so cute and small and helpless
whatever we want to protect them because
now they are helpless you know like they
can they are now like the weakness the
empathy comes in yeah but also at the
same time like whenever I see that I was
like oh he's so cute and then in the
back of my head's like he was what if he
was rapist what if he was super racist
yeah then what if he owned slaves yeah
we don't know because we're only seeing
the outside but I'm sure like if I got
to know him he came up to me he's like
what's up you [ __ ] yellow ball
yeah we're talking yeah okay you go yeah
sit over there with a door locked break
your hip or something so it's I think
it's just the initial like the at the
outside that's all but I don't think
that anyone would oppose to throwing him
in a [ __ ] home you find out that he
molested like 600 kids or something you
know yeah yeah yeah some people some old
people should be left there that's why I
see sometimes I see articles about like
old woman in home hasn't been visited in
over 10 years it's like oh my God that's
so sad but sometimes what'd you do you
know yeah why is this one comment that
says working in nursing homes I've seen
cute little old ladies where no one
visits thinking it's so cruel of their
families to just leave them and ignore
them after digging finding out they were
actually pretty abusive toward their
kids in their younger years
they're less dementia written days it's
strange and makes you see them in such a
difficult different way yeah also I feel
like being being put in a home is kind
oh instead of just what's the
alternative yeah letting them die in the
[ __ ] armchair in the living room
right or yeah like not having any care
for them at all to where they'll
ultimately just die like in some
apartment somewhere yeah like even more
neglect yeah I feel like bad people that
end up in nursing homes and don't get
visited people that are paying for that
nursing home is still being nice yeah
well a lot of times two no one's paying
for in the state is paying for it is
that how it works the state pays for it
or like the VA if they were veterans is
paying for it but that level of care is
so bad yeah and there's a lot of like
elder abuse that goes on in there but
it's almost like
if there was someone in your life who
cared about you then you wouldn't have
made it to that position also some
people I think are just like they've
like everyone around them has just
passed and so it's unfortunate that they
have no one that's true but then yeah
there's probably like their their
medical conditions are too much of a
burden for anyone else to really take on
where they need medical attention yeah
at a home but then it's like the
abandoned part where it's like no one
comes to the end but no one ever sees
them it's like yeah if they've never
really did anything wrong and they're
not a terrible person that happens
that's really sad there's there's I'm
sure a lot of cases where that's
actually really sad of course but yeah
if they were shitty people [ __ ] them
I feel like so have you guys ever spoken
to your parents at all about like end of
Life Care yeah like what is what is your
my dad told me to please never put me at
home I'm like dude I would rather kill
myself first you're living with me yeah
no matter where I go how like where I am
in life I'm I would never leave you at
home I love my Dad yeah yeah I'm pretty
close with my dad too I feel like so
based on conversations that I've
overheard with my dad and his brother
based on conversations I've kind of just
had with my dad in general he hasn't
said directly but I feel like if he gets
to a point where he can't take care of
himself that like he's gonna figure out
a way to just leave
and then but if like it's if he's
otherwise fine like then I would I would
not put him in a home like I would help
figure something out like personally I
would do that but I feel like his leave
like he would figure out a way to just
unalive oh damn because like there were
some conversations I've heard where like
a friend of theirs like had some sort of
tumor all of a sudden their health
decline couldn't he was just [ __ ]
himself you know like and then so like
someone helped him unalive himself and
then my dad him and his brother were
kind of like yeah that's like the way to
go you know like kind of making a joke
like take the dog out back and shoot him
kind of thing like just let it
just into the suffering if they're if
the person's no longer really there yeah
what's that called that assistant yeah
so I feel like totally be a mean like a
I know an organ that's a thing important
in order oh really yeah I didn't think
we have that anywhere in the U.S in the
US but it's okay like medically like a
medical reason yeah yeah there's a few
States like I think maybe like two I
didn't know that I thought you had to go
like literally leave the country I
didn't know I remember reading about it
before in Oregon that's awesome because
I'm like oh that's the closest one to me
yeah that should be a human right I
think so yeah absolutely especially if
you've written that out before You've
Lost Your faculties yeah if we can
and the suffering of animals with
euthanasia then we should totally be
able to make that choice ourselves when
we're at our point where we can't do
anything there was this concept that uh
someone designed like a roller coaster
oh yeah it's like a death roller coaster
yeah like it kills you absolutely not
there's like nine nine that's like
circles yeah no I think they were pretty
cool for you because you're watching my
[ __ ] way that's an unpopular opinion
right there can you imagine
can you just pass out from the G the
g-force and then you just you die you
don't know that you're dead I'm
imagining like your friends and family
are surrounding your your cart
everyone's just waving and then all of a
sudden you hear
hands and feet inside yeah
that's the last thing you want your
family to see yeah I want them to see my
hair
[Music]
on the screen you scream 12. she's alive
and then she's gone if you want to buy a
coffee
I read recently that they're working on
uh suicide booths Too boots
for this [ __ ] photo that's so good we
don't need like little mini versions of
it too you know you slumped over yeah
Victorian times where they would take
pictures of the Dead they did yeah they
would take family portraits with the
dead oh God I need to go darn and now
I'm going to be looking that up later
thanks for that so thank you
um pictures import pictures were really
expensive so they would save it for
really really special occasions so when
they have someone die in the family
that's the only time they can get a
photo so they prop them up they prop
them up dress them up and then their
eyes are closed so well that's why when
you look at these photos because these
cameras take so long like the exposure
is if you look at the photos the dead
person's perfectly clear because they're
not moving but people around here
they're kind of blurry it's a little bit
blurry oh my God that is abhorrent I
can't believe humans are so weird this
roller coaster thing is still in my head
I love it so much what is the blue thing
I don't remember I read this this booth
one more recently the Pod one I've heard
that one yeah but you just press a
button and it like replaces the oxygen
and then you just like pass it out yeah
and then you're done yes
instantly almost I would think I would
do that well I feel like instant because
don't you like suffocate or something I
think you wouldn't no like I think you
wouldn't
know that you're suffocating like you
would be gone before you were
suffocating kind of like oh you wouldn't
be aware hopefully how do they test that
the way that I would want to go out have
you ever like gone under for surgery or
whatever so like I would like that
propofol it's like really quick right
like you go under really fast then after
that once you're already out then they
give you whatever to wake you up because
it's just instantly don't they do that
with the Lethal Lethal Injections but I
don't think it actually they're not
using like the good [ __ ] so it can
actually be like painful painful yeah
Kitty hi kitty yeah at the uh I've seen
videos of the um
what is it uh assisted suicide and they
do injections no there's I think she
took some pills or I don't know a
medicine is just a drink and they
suggest you eat chocolate with it
because it's so bitter so she was
drinking chocolate's also initiating
and then she would eat pieces of
chocolate and then her family's around
her surrounding her and she just falls
asleep that's it yeah I mean the pill
form I don't know if that's fast enough
I mean like the when you're literally
get injected with purple fall like
you're just gone you're just out you
know like when you get put under so I
feel like that's pretty dope it's so
nice yeah then you wake up and you're
like oh I just all this [ __ ] happened to
Bean I had no idea wait you wake up
after you die no like when you get put
on surgery yeah you could have died in
the middle of that and
it would have been fine yeah like I
wouldn't yeah like it would have been
the easiest way to die everyone else is
freaking out but I'm crazy yeah that was
pretty [ __ ] chill yeah what was I so
worried about my whole life
okay here's another one summer is the
worst season and every second of it is
torture wow I love so many I hate the
heat huh they probably live in Texas
probably what's so fun about being
cooked when entering a car wasps
annoying the [ __ ] out of you and
constantly sweating going to the beach
isn't Fun in that and they're using
Celsius so I'm not gonna use the numbers
because it's confused oh they don't
count then
swimming in cold weather weather is
better what the [ __ ]
weird I I will say though I used to be
such a summer person but I'm leaning
more towards like fall and winter now
because I think like fashion is better
yeah like I like this always been my
favorite season yeah I don't like layers
the only reason why I like it more in
the fall Winters because I just like
wearing sweats all day and no one says
anything you know I like being able to
like all of my best clothes are winter
clothes like I spend more money I have
like a 500 like pea code and like all
this like I love spending money on
winter clothes summer clothes I'm like
I'm just gonna buy some [ __ ] from Lulu's
yeah some crap like sundresses because I
hate it like I'm uncomfortable I'm
sweaty so I agree with this person I
like
to see the Sun and I like to see the
beach and I like to be at the beach for
short periods of time but typically most
of my life I would prefer to just be in
not humid cool weather so it's like I
would like to just be at the beach in an
air-conditioned tent
yeah we're like on a on one of those
like in like one of those really nice
like condos that's just like inside
looking at the summer yes I like to look
at summer but I really like to be in
summer yeah I know ever since developing
the sun allergy of mine I really don't
like sunny weather anymore and
it hurts like it actually hurts me to
feel the Rays of sun on my skin now like
not like painful hurt but like it
bothers me yeah like it bothers me
because I know well the the moment that
I feel the sun on my skin it's bothering
me because I know what comes after yeah
because in that moment it's not painful
but later it's gonna be painful and I'm
gonna suffer for like two days it's
stressful and yeah and so I really
dislike it so whenever we're on vacation
now I in my purse I have an umbrella
with me and I'm that lady that's
constantly with the umbrella like like
yeah I'm like [ __ ] get away and then
so and then also because you know Luca
is so young now he's almost seven months
old so he can use sunscreen but all this
time though he's been too young to use
sunscreen because they get rashes like
babies get rashes if you have sunscreen
well sunscreen like I get rashes from
sunscreen that's crazy yeah I it's
pretty it's pretty hard on your skin
yeah if you have sensitive skin so I
haven't been putting sunscreen on him at
all instead I'm just like so anal about
him having zero Sun touch him I'm like
yeah no well even an umbrella is not
enough like because the reflective Rays
can get well it's the the car seat thing
plus the umbrella yeah and then like
we'll take walks sometimes and then
Casey's like he's fine he's under the
thing and I'm like no he needs the
umbrella too we have double protection
yeah he thinks I'm crazy but people
would always make fun of me because I
would wear those like long sleeve rash
guards yeah like the long sleeve likes
yeah [ __ ] scuba looking pants and
stuff and I'm like do you want me to die
what do you think you think I think this
is [ __ ] is cool it's not cool you gotta
link me because I need to get some of
those you can find it it's super easy
yeah it's like a rash guard rash guard
is that the scuba gear looking thing
yeah but it's like that it's very thin
material like uh does that help protect
that it's like 100 UV oh [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah I gotta get some because I I have
like the scuba looking thing the real
the thick one but yeah you don't need
that because that's too hot yeah unless
you're too hard to put it cold yeah
water but it's really hard to put on too
no it's like those women pants basically
like you could just wear Lululemon pants
and like a and then buy the rash guard
same material it's like thin but like no
sun can get through it yeah I need to
get that but yeah the piece the person
that everyone's laughing at because
you're like fine head to toe dressed on
the beach we'll go to the beach together
and we won't be weird but my favorite
season has always been fall because my
most favorite favorite favorite [ __ ]
thing in the world is right after it's
rained and the Sun comes out I just said
I didn't like sunlight but the Sun comes
out and it like the air is crisp and
when it's cold out like yeah when it's
cold it has to be cold yeah and it's
just like ah I love it but walking to
school fresh air in the morning yeah
any like cold
air
after rain so nice nice when it's yeah
because it's not humid because it's not
hot so it's not like yeah it's the cold
that's not evaporating all hot and nasty
you know yeah we should rain more in
SoCal man
yeah that would be nice yeah when I was
in Florida it was raining a lot because
it was hurricane season
and Casey and I like we were playing
around with the idea of living there and
I'm like I could totally live here no no
no no we're in Seattle Florida yeah oh
it's [ __ ] hot now so no I know the
hot party the hot part it kind of kills
it but the rain part I being a SoCal
girl like I usually hate the rain but
being there at that time even though it
was like I kind of like that it was warm
and raining I don't know I'm kind of
contradicting what I'm saying yeah but I
liked it where I'm like I could see
myself living here I'm sure it's nice
I've only been to Orlando one time so I
don't have much of an opinion on Florida
but unpopular opinion Florida is
probably nice it's probably nice
from New York go there so it can't be
that bad all right let's try another one
arranged marriages don't get the credit
they deserve oh
maybe we should get some context on this
one yeah with the person's comments I
don't know how they don't give contact
well no yeah what I'm saying is maybe
instead of just reading the house I
should read the whole thing are there
any comments that agree and why
um well let me give you what they are
saying historically there was a great
need for marriage arguably our survival
depended on it when two people get
together for deep cultural slash
religious reasons even if they've had
some level of choice the prevailing glue
in their relationship is a deep
connection to the same ideology
however and and out society today I
don't know what that means in society
today especially Western ones our
beliefs are more varied than ever more
fractured marriage easily is a choice
not a need on the surface this is a good
thing however it does make for the
ingredients that drive a couple to
marriage in a western Society we're
taught you could have it any way you
want and are met with endless choices or
at least a perception of them coupled
with fomo if you are stuck on an island
with the person you were dating now
you'd make the most of it why because
you have no choice
religion offers this feeling as well and
there's something liberating it about it
and as much as I loathe the idea for
many it's simply easy to make a choice
in some areas of their lives with
relationships being an exception and
this is where I get to my point two
people that were arranged to be married
share one thing that they don't have the
pressure of making the right decision
any frustration they have they can blame
it on not being it not being within
their control they must just play the
cards they were dealt while the rest of
us keep thinking we have an endless
amount of hands before playing the river
I want to add one thing clearly anyone
being forced into it is a non-starter so
I guess what he's saying is we have
harder times maintaining a stable family
because it could always be better too
many choices and all of that stuff so
he's just saying give some credit to the
fact of like well neither of us really
have a choice this is what our religion
has told us we're both committed to the
idea of what our religion has said so
we're just going to make this work
anyway yeah they're not saying like oh
like women forced into marriage or
whatever but just like if two adults two
consenting adults who believe in the
ideology
are agreeing to be involved in arranged
marriages then it's almost like this is
not something that I have to choose and
then like then all of a sudden that's
going to be my happiness it's like oh
I'm just doing this as a service to my
community or my family my religion or
whatever so you just kind of stick with
it and make it work I guess yeah I mean
that makes sense if you take away
yeah if there's no if there's too many
choices it's hard it's like the menu at
Cheesecake Factory yeah yeah that's
usually a sign of a bad kitchen by the
way my dad always told me this he said
if the menu is too big yeah the food's
gonna be trash because it's all Frozen
[ __ ] that they just like slap together I
know but my one exception is Cheesecake
Factory I don't know why I love it so
much even though I worked there and I
said it is crappy food
after ordered one dish there ever you
get the same thing every time same thing
chicken which one is your is it the
Pasta Da Vinci pasta I still love that
[ __ ] can we go to Cheesecake Factory
after this I'm down you're going back
home
you want Cheesecake Factory you're like
you're going back to the desert with no
food and you want cheesecake back I just
want that brown bread I know what is in
that bread I have no idea it's not wheat
it's like sugar it's brown sugar brown
sugar bread that's why it's so delicious
I know I always call it the chocolate
bread but there's no chocolate we used
to hate people that would come in like
we used to make fun of people like and
see how many different names that they
come up with for this damn breakfast
brown bread look at the chocolate bread
it's like it's not chocolate it's not
chocolate but that's why people think
it's chocolate it's [ __ ] sugary yeah
sugar bread
here's some responses if you steal
someone's ability to make a choice then
it does become easier to make a choice
yeah can a person still be happy without
freedoms or choices sure would I like my
choices taken from me no but if that's a
problem for you go on ahead and restrict
yourself
it's like the starkiest [ __ ] yeah
go on ahead I mean I've heard about some
arranged marriages that do workout yeah
and that's that's cool like if it worked
out for you that's awesome yeah it's
amazing to me like whenever I hear about
happy couples you know I'm like really I
feel like that's what it takes though is
to be in a position where you are no
longer it's no longer about you anymore
yeah to make it like about the marriage
or about the family or yeah the culture
I feel like a lot of people who have
actually stayed married for 40 or 50
years they've defaulted to that because
I don't think that they're necessarily
in that honeymoon love anymore they're
like well we made this Choice our family
needs us to stay together we would like
for our family to feel like a unit so
we're gonna make this work I feel like
but they actually got the upper hand of
being able to choose that person to
begin with so that just seems like
maybe a lot of marriage is that anyway
like by the time you've picked someone
and you go through all this [ __ ]
it's gonna suck regardless of if you
pick them or not so like we get the we
get to pick the person to at least go
through that but I think the thing is
too that the people that are stuck in
the arranged marriage ideology like they
never got any options or they never got
anything whereas
we still know that we have a choice so
we will just get divorced and I don't
know if I would have uh trust my parents
are choosing a nice person for me
yeah this other person said I'd rather
be alone than with someone I only
tolerate or don't really like or
actually even hate
this concept benefits men the most
hardly ever benefits women that's
probably very true I feel like I've read
somewhere and I don't know if it's true
or not but I read somewhere that men are
happier and healthier when they're in a
relationship but women are less happy
and less healthy because it's basically
like they're spending all of their
efforts taking care and yeah
I heard about um makes sense like Middle
Eastern marriages where he has like
multiple wives and the wives don't care
because they only seem like once a month
they have their own house yeah their own
car yeah because the dude's rich as [ __ ]
yeah
purely transactional it's like oh I
wonder what the interactions are though
right that she does have to deal with
where I'm like tell me a little bit more
detail before I sign up for this yeah
from what I've seen like like they're
happy like it's just chilly comes over
hangs out whatever probably bang and
it's like all right see you next month
oh here's my and I imagine there's got
to be some sort of probably there's a
bunch of kids I don't know there's
probably some reason why that's not
great but I'm sure I don't know all of
the details yeah it could be great it
could also be terrible and abusive who
knows yeah unless you've actually been
in it or you're in that
no idea
here's another one being into shoes is
the weirdest hobby there is what
what I simply don't understand the
appeal of collecting shoes compared to
literally anything else my cat just
knocked over a plant sorry can you just
knocked over planned I agree you cannot
wear more than one pair a day and they
take a massive amount of space to store
and display excluding Footwear for
special weather conditions you do not
need more than three pairs of shoes and
even then that's a lot work sport formal
well they're kind of extreme in their
opinion that's extreme but I could see
no more than like maybe six because you
got like a brown pair black pair a
colored pair wow heels sandals you know
what's funny for me agreeing with his
this opinion I have way too many you
have like a whole garage I have a whole
cupboard thing of multiple drawers full
of shoes yeah you have a [ __ ] ton I have
too many shoes you do but then when I'm
trying to like I have an outfit and I'm
like [ __ ] I don't have the shoes for
this outfit
even though you have like 10 000 pairs
in your garage yeah that's why like if
you hypocrite wardrobe is very minimal
sure I get it where are your new
balances forever you know it's fine you
wore a black pair of New Balances sure
yeah that sounds even worse for some
reason I think I'll buy a black pair of
New Balances sounds worse than a white
pair but you know well I mean that
person clearly does just just doesn't
care about fashion we care more about
fashion plus what we do for a living too
you know but that we can't even use our
shoes for free for free free today tip
is referring to her toes yeah they're
Wild and Free they're one camera today
something that tells a gross man this is
[ __ ] comments from these creepy ass
dudes it's gonna be [ __ ] weird as
[ __ ] well they know that you creepy well
they say they say creepy [ __ ] at least
they're giving us some uh what's the
word interaction that one engagement
engagement [ __ ] venmo her dude this
person said I mean couldn't your
argument here be applied to literally
anything and that's true yeah like
people don't understand why you would
collect any anything collecting okay my
opinion collecting [ __ ] in general is
stupid and wasteful
collecting literally anything why do you
need a [ __ ] ton of stuff yeah I collect
magnets when I travel on your fridge no
so I actually have them in a box I used
to have them in a fridge now hold on we
don't even let them do their job wait
wait so I had them on our fridge magnet
I mean uh the magnets on our fridge for
a long time as I was collecting them I
absolutely loved having them on the
fridge because every time I'd go to the
fridge I'd be like I remember when we
went to Rome oh I remember Tokyo and
like I'd be like looking I'm like I
remember when I bought this magnet and
then I remember the trip and like it's
like tiny little like memory uh Journeys
every time you go to the fridge but I
didn't like how it looked like with the
aesthetic of the house so now that we
moved to this house
I'm like I don't want magnets on the
fridge it looks tacky like I'm good like
I don't wanna it is I don't want to see
it but like also a lot of new fridges
for some reason aren't matte like you
can Bailey whatever they're made out of
you can't put magnets oh like even the
stainless steel ones I don't know what
it's made out of but I've like had
because I live in like a new apartment
every year basically so I've had a lot
of different fridges and I'm like oh I
literally can't even put one magnet like
one magnet so I can put like a note or
like a wedding invitation or just
something that will be temporary there
and magnets won't stick to the fridge
and I'm like what the hell is that's
weird that metal is bad because I feel
like magnets on fridges and it just
makes a home a home it's very like old
school old school it's traditional it's
before Instagram and everything had to
be true because then that's where we put
our pictures our homes were uglier
before Instagram let's be honest yeah so
I now have had all of my magnet
collection in a box and I've been adding
to it every time I travel still
um and Casey was like well you should
figure out what to do with the all these
magnets you should see them I'm like
yeah I remember I miss my little memory
getaways
and I was like wait we have another
fridge in the in the garage that no one
[ __ ] sees yeah we have an extra
fridge here I'm gonna I haven't done it
yet but my plan is to put all my magnets
in the garage fridge so I could see them
you should do a like hang up like a
metal sheet frame or metal that's what I
was thinking yeah you can make a garage
yeah we don't have enough wall space for
that but that's a good idea because
cabinets with shoes yeah there's all
cabinets and shoes no but the reason why
another reason why I didn't like the
magnets on the fridge though is because
every time we'd open it and close it
like some of them will fall off and then
they break yeah
yeah I can imagine if you had enough of
them you could make like some sort of
framed art I think I have enough magnets
to fill this whole wall yeah like I have
so many magnets and then that could be
like a kind of like a man cave type of
art or something like if you have a a
big enough house you have like a room
with a bar in it or something then you
could make art out of it but true this
one's a weird one it says I love it when
people bring babies to work
I might have to disagree but [ __ ] why
I work from home now but back in the
office days I loved it when co-workers
brought their babies or toddlers into
the office because they like kids but I
love how we're talking about this when
my child is in the other room but this
doesn't really work though this is work
but it's not because it's not like going
yeah it's not like it's like a bunch of
people you don't [ __ ] know you
probably don't even [ __ ] like half of
them if you're doing [ __ ] you don't want
to do like that's a job this is us just
hanging out we happen to make money off
of it yeah if I was like miserable at a
[ __ ] like like in an office job and I
hear you're [ __ ] baby crying I'm
throwing in the paper shredder
[ __ ] that kid have you seen a paper
shredder on TV how are you gonna throw a
baby in that little finger one finger at
a time one finger at a time
just put them inside with all the paper
shirts his clothes
yeah I mean I don't know I don't really
have an opinion on that because I have
children of my own and I like other
children I like babies so I would like
to interact with other babies so this
guy says you might be onto something
here let offices be the workplace
environment for parents who want to give
their spouses a break from crying babies
and other drama like kind of like the
opposite like a lot of people are
working from home now it's like they
want to get away oh wait no like a lot
of people working from home now so like
they're having to work while their kids
are like also running crazy in the
background but then so then like the
people that are going into the office
now are just the people trying to get
away from them exactly yeah so then if
you made it the opposite like let people
take their kids into the office so I can
get some work done from home that's
funny that's kind of cute someone just
said basically like me I'm neutral on
kids if they're well behaved they're
fine but they sometimes they get on my
nerves yeah it's like all the adults in
the office do right exactly annoying ass
adults in the office it's a distraction
though it's like like having it like I
when I was younger I applied to work at
some pet company Corporation whatever
like you'd actually bring your dog into
work and I thought oh that's kind of
cool but I thought about it more and I
was like nah because like people's pets
like constantly interrupting what you're
doing like there's all it's always like
wrangling so yeah Casey hated it when
people would bring their dogs to the
office yeah because he has an allergy
too allergic first of all second of all
it's just so distracting because like
they're coming around they're licking
him he's over here like itching and even
though his office door would be closed
like they're barking and like there's
just so much
I would be in heaven I would love that
it's so that's kind of like if you love
babies you'd be like oh my God there's
babies in the office I'm like gonna take
10 minutes from what I'm doing [ __ ] you
love babies shut up you love them she's
over here pretending she's pretending
like she doesn't like babies
I can see right through you this one is
not unpopular I don't think but okay
spending money on alcohol and getting
wasted and hungover is the worst way to
spend your weekend I mean that's just
pointing out like why does everyone do
this every weekend basically I've ever
once in a while it's fine I get it but
every weekend so like I what I've
noticed about myself is like my hormones
control what I feel like doing so
there's one weekend out of the month
where I have a [ __ ] fire in my ass I
want to get [ __ ] up I want to like
dance or like meet someone or like make
out with somebody like I want to dance
let's go [ __ ] dance right and then
like the other three weeks out of the
month I'm like God get me the [ __ ] away
from these people like I just want to
watch Netflix or like go shopping like I
got a Target run to do like so I don't
know I can see why it's fun sometimes
but then yeah if it's every single
weekend then what is
but also what are we doing with our life
anyway honestly some people want to
escape it that's fine yeah
I mean we never teached our own because
yeah to people that do that every
weekend they don't see it as a waste
yeah I guess if you're enjoying it I
dated someone like that and it's like
every weekend like don't you want to
find something
better like a little more what are you
running away from homely to like build
like spend some time building your your
life outside of work like what other
things could you be doing like
decorating your apartment or like the
just things to like build a life yeah
it's like but also it's like what are
you escaping from and
the only times you see your friends is
when you guys go out to get shit-faced
and then you hungover but never have any
real meaningful friendships you know
yeah it's like especially at past like a
certain age it's like what's going on
here this isn't normal yeah you're just
like working for the weekend so like
you're just doing what you have to do
from Monday through Friday 5 PM so that
you can just block the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah that's definitely I think that's
probably a sign of you're not happy with
your life at all yeah because I can't
imagine like not wanting to just rest
yeah and like enjoy other things so yeah
yeah there's probably some addictive
some issues there
here's another one people in
relationships shouldn't take advice from
their friends ever
you feel about that no because I should
have taken y'all's advice
[Laughter]
really
instead of taking advice from the wrong
friend no but yeah no it's fine to take
advice from your friends when you need
help because sometimes you need an
outside perspective yeah you know
I guess it's probably better to like see
what they think and why see does it
apply to you yeah what do they not know
yeah right what do they not know what do
they do know what are you ignoring that
they know I just don't want to [ __ ]
hear like what do you think
I mean I'm the worst culprit of this I
literally would come to you guys with
all my relationship problems and hear
your opinions and hear your thoughts and
like just have it be a bouncing board
kind of place for my emotions and
feelings and
yeah and I don't know I feel like taking
myself out of being me though I would
feel really guilty like to be that
friend that's like constantly having
issues like throwing it on my friend's
laps and like I just I felt like I was
annoying everyone where it's like God
damn it tip again where I just felt
really also because there were certain
friends that literally told me that too
which I literally were like if you don't
take their advice the day what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you yeah I don't want to
hear it again yeah I told you what the
answer is so yeah if you don't want to
do it I don't care it made me really
self-conscious to like ever air out any
of my feelings isolated yeah so then I
don't know like them saying like you
should never take it or what is it you
should never take advice from saying
yeah people in relationships should not
take relationship advice from their
friends like ever yeah I don't know
relationship marriage counselors have
master's degrees at a minimum your
friends probably have the worst advice
in the world when it comes to dealing
with problems if you go to your friends
obviously their opinion will be biased
to favor you complaining about your
partner to people in your social group
will achieve nothing except one make it
really make people in your life really
dislike or distrust your partner two you
may be only adding to the problem
because you and your allies will not see
the problems you may not see the problem
that you may be contributing to the
situation
um whereas someone who is impartial can
and three May minimize your own
contribution to the problem to save face
or not share everything you've done yeah
like you know yeah I agree I agree with
it so it's like kind of an unfair
I guess they're saying it's like an
unfair like if you need help go actually
yeah and like like your mom you might
not want to tell the whole truth of the
problem too because like you're don't
want your friends to maybe know like
everything or whatever so that they're
giving you advice based on partial
truths right and then it's just biased
anyway I I see that point and I agree I
think the other part though is like you
have your friends like your friends are
your friends and you are attracting
people that like you value their
opinions you value what they think
so for me personally like I turn to you
guys because I felt like I wanted to
hear your thoughts on the situation I
was going through because I felt so lost
and I trust you guys and I value your
opinions and I wanted
to just hear you out it doesn't mean
that it's like you were dictating my
next move right like I just wanted to
like well we lit we like as a friend
group we have our own little Community
right so it's kind of like feedback this
person I'm trying to bring into the
community or this person that's already
in the community
like how do like we all have to
figure out how to like live together
right it's like if this person's always
going to be around how does this affect
the rest of us yeah or like how are they
affecting you like you we are protecting
you now like how so it's there there is
some case where like the group or your
friends like having an opinion but it's
obviously your choice at the end of what
you're gonna do with it yeah so I
wouldn't say never yeah you know it's
okay too sometimes you know there's
probably like a point where it's too
much or right yeah that's why I feel
like it's like sorry I feel like I keep
interrupting you
um I feel like having your friend's
opinion coupled with therapy yeah is I
think a pretty good mixer your therapist
too would be like so what do your
friends think of him and if you're like
the therapist would be like man why do
you think they all hate him you know
yeah so it's kind of like a good it's
like data Gathering like right you know
if so many people agree on something why
why Drew right he's kind of a [ __ ]
douchebag did you hear that seven eight
times and then one person's like no I
actually kind of like him and it's like
I'm just gonna listen to this one person
because I kind of want to like him too
you know like
sorry got out of that yeah it took me a
while but I got out of it yeah um no I
mean it's it's I mean of course some
friends will give you [ __ ] advice like
that one uh that one thing that we've
read before where uh that woman said
that her best friend suggested that they
test her husband oh yeah like some
people have [ __ ] ass advice but it's
okay to go to your friends for advice
sometimes it's like it's not a never
yeah because you guys have given me
great advice just yesterday like you
yeah yesterday yeah what did I say
yesterday
yeah
great advice but not good memory
I forgot what I said you say a lot of
good things that's why yeah they just
there's so many tell me which one it was
let's do one more I think we got room
for one more
um
okay no that one's probably too crazy
um wanting to try human meat is not
weird okay no it is weird and you should
be jailed when it's ethically sourced if
there is yes there it is like yeah yes
there is there's this consent like see
if it's like Gina I wanna I wanna show
you with me I'm like oh bro dude like
here I'll surgically have my part of my
meat here removed no literally I did a
Jay can use uh article on someone who
had their leg amputated or something
like that and they they got their leg
meat and had their friends come over to
taste their yeah his leg ethical it's
not weird I'm just curious
I heard it tastes like pork
they do call this long pork and the skin
yeah
cannibals but it is
is it no like it's like in the Bible or
something they're calling her own pork
and then it's what it's very I've never
read the Bible I haven't either it's
called this long pork it's very similar
to Pork I don't remember where it came
from pork because our bodies are longer
than the long than a pig it's it's like
the every like it tastes or you know
texture is so so similar so we're like
the fatty kind of tan instead of a red
meat I don't know because when I look at
my muscle I feel like it's like a red
meat like a cow but you've seen your
muscle haven't you ever cut into
something deep enough to kind of see
muscle no but like it's it's like a
that's why when tattoo artists they
practice on Pork yeah
so the skin is the same like very
similar they also apparently practice on
oranges long oranges
[Music]
all right here's our final one people
exaggerate how hard food service jobs
really are what I work at a fast food
restaurant right now it's by no means a
fun job and it can be very frustrating
but can so so can every job I have
co-workers that are constantly bitching
about every customer that comes in they
take it so personally I think it's
because a lot of these jobs work by
teenagers it's a lot of unnecessary
stress to add to Young people's lives
which I can be sympathetic to however
I've had co-workers look at me with a
straight face and tell me that I must be
enjoying my new job as a laborer at a
construction site because it's easier
than food service so many people I've
met in the industry just can't do their
job without complaining and act like
they've got the worst job on Earth while
simultaneously refusing to do the actual
gross work like cleaning the grease
traps or taking out the garbage no I
mean it's hard but it's not the hardest
is there the hardest job ever what's the
hardest job ever like some like
sometimes I see videos on like the
internet water welding yeah it's like
some extremely crazy manual labor job
that honestly only men would probably
really want to do like the worst of the
worst like where your arms could get cut
off like at any moment's notice like
fixing wind turbines
crab crab fishing yeah the the were the
ones where people die the most yeah like
no one's dying at yeah you know Arby's I
mean actually yeah did you hear about
that guy that got killed over McDonald's
fries
yeah like if you chill yeah if you're
chill you don't fight back you know you
probably won't die it's it's a hard job
but it does suck super hard like oh
probably you're like complaining all day
long it's like it's not that bad you
know like I've worked as a waitress
before as I host this before it's
exhausting it's exhausting I'm working
in a restaurant you're running back and
forth for like eight hours you know like
so it's tiring and dealing with people
is not easy because so many different
people's personalities come in but every
job though on like us from a certain
level down just [ __ ] sucks like any
type of service cleaning you know like
this I do feel I I do agree though
people do over exaggerate how bad it is
yeah yeah I didn't think it was bad when
I worked in the positions I've had like
a like at a restaurant yeah so I worked
at HomeTown Buffet as a Hostess but also
I I helped like pick up the like busting
plates yeah busting or whatever
and in Mexico I was a waitress at my
uncle's room yeah a restaurant yeah that
one was kind of like it was kind of hard
because I would had a really bad memory
and we weren't allowed or not allowed
but like it was like looked down upon if
you had a pad to write down everyone's
notes or food orders and I'd be like
I'm so sorry what did you ask for again
that's ridiculous do you want them to
get their food right or do you want me
to have a [ __ ] pet you know shut up
that's dumb I'm glad when I worked at
Hooters like we were allowed to write
[ __ ] down there like y'all are all
probably dumb as [ __ ] like just go ahead
and take a pad like write it down yeah
sometimes I miss working at the
Cheesecake Factory I do my favorite job
yeah sometimes I miss like because
there's like a different level of
camaraderie it's almost like being in
high school or college like we forced
friends and then you're all like under
the same like ridiculous situations yeah
like the movie Waiting yeah like there
is some Nostalgia that I have for
working that kind of job so it is tough
though there's times where I was just
like [ __ ] pissed Mother's Day
Mother's Day at Cheesecake Factory oh in
Glendale oh man yeah that's even worse
but yeah it is a camaraderie of like
oh the bartenders have their own crew
whatever and then the waiters and like
someone's sleeping with that one yeah
the managers are fun like we went to a
company picnic picnic we saw the manager
making out with one of the waitresses in
the car like it's like this is fun yeah
I was when I was at Hooters one of the
girls was dating one of the managers
which is strictly forbidden because he
was like 45 and we were like 22. so
obviously it was disgusting yeah you
know but it's there's the drama it's
like its own little soap opera and like
it's fun it's like a boot camp and a
soap opera and like a party time and
then also kind of like boring all at the
same time you know like and boring and
boring like when there's no one you have
like six tables and there's no one Adam
you're just like [ __ ] what am I doing
that was fun yes I think that was a good
episode we might do uh some of these
again in the future unpopular opinions
yeah write yours down below let us know
if you disagree with any of our takes I
imagine you may
you're wrong
check out our sponsors leave a comment
for the engagement hit the like button
if you feel so and if you feel like you
liked it
thank you guys bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]